ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ SAYS
AND GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
OTHER SIDE, TOMI.
>> FIRST OF ALL, JUST STOP,
ANYONE WHO IS USING THE WORD
"URGENT" AROUND YOU CONSCIOUSLY
IS TRYING TO INVOKE MILITARISTIC
FRAME, THIS IS NOT A SEARCH,
THESE ARE CHILDREN AND THEY ARE
NOT INSURGENTS.
AND WE ARE NOT BEING INVADED.
>> Tomi: I WOULD HAVE TO
DISAGREE WITH ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, WE ARE BEING
INVADED WHEN YOU HAVE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE COMING
OVER EVERY MONTH, SET TO REACH A
MILLION THIS YEAR, THAT IS AN
INVASION AND EVERYBODY LOOKS AT
THOSE IMAGES FROM THESE
DETENTION FACILITIES AND FEELS
VERY BADLY FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS, NOBODY WANTS TO BE
IN THAT POSITION BUT I WILL TELL
YOU THIS BECAUSE I HAVE VISITED
THOSE FACILITIES AND SPENT A LOT
OF TIME WITH BORDER PATROL
AGENTS AND THOSE THAT ARE TASKED
WITH THEIR CARE,, AND OF THESE
IMAGES LOOK BAD, I KNOW THAT’S
NOT WHAT ANYONE WANTS TO SEE BUT
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND, BORDER
PATROL AGENTS ARE BEING
OVERWHELMED RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE BEING RELEGATED TO
BABYSITTERS, THEY ARE NOT ABLE
TO DO THEIR ACTUAL JOBS AND THEY
ARE DOING THE BEST THEY CAN WITH
THE RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE SO
WE NEED TO COME TOGETHER AS A
NATION AND DECIDE HOW WE ARE
GOING TO GET BORDER PATROL
BETTER RESOURCES BUT AS JOHN
JAMES SAID AT THE TOP OF THIS
BLOCK WE REALLY NEED TO DO IS
STOP INCENTIVIZING PEOPLE TO
COME OVER HERE.
THESE ARE CHILDREN, ABSOLUTELY,
THEY ARE INNOCENT CHILDREN BUT
THEY ARE BEING INCENTIVIZED TO
COME OVER HERE, THEIR PARENTS
ARE SENDING THEM OVER HERE, THEY
KNOW THEY WILL ONLY BE HELD FOR
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF DAYS,
POSSIBLY MOVED TO A CONVENTION
CENTER AND BE GIVEN SCHOOL
SCHOOLING AND HOUSING AND
EVENTUALLY RELEASED AND THEIR
PARENTS WILL BE ABLE TO COME
RIGHT ALONG WITH THEM.
WE HAVE TO STOP INCENTIVIZING IT
BUT I WILL DISAGREE WITH SOME OF
THE POINTS THAT WERE MADE AS FAR
AS NOBODY HAS TACKLE THIS
PROBLEM, DONALD J. TRUMP TACKLED
THIS PROBLEM, HIS ZERO-TOLERANCE
POLICY THAT SAID DO NOT COME
OVER HERE IF YOU DO NOT WANT TO
BE SEPARATED, DO NOT CROSS THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY, DO NOT COME.
WE ARE BUILDING A WALL AND
TAKING IMMIGRATION SERIOUSLY, WE
HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO PROTECT AND
DEFEND THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
BORDER, THAT WAS WORKING.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CAME IN
WITH THEIR VIRTUE SIGNALING
ANDREW THAT ALL AWAY AND NOW
EVERYBODY SUFFERS, THE MIGRANT
CHILDREN SUFFER, THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYER SUFFER.
IT HAS TO START WITH SECURING
THE BORDER.
>> Emily: GILLIAN, YOUR FLOOR?
>> Gillian: FIRST OF ALL I
WOULD SAY, IF PRESIDENT BIDEN
WOKE UP TOMORROW AND DID WHAT
EVERY REPUBLICAN LAWMAKER AND
EVERY TRUMP SUPPORTER WANTS HIM
TO DO WHICH IS TO REINSTATE THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY, WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN TO THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN IN
PARTICULAR, FAMILIES BUT
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS MOST
SPECIFICALLY WHO WOULD THEN BE
LEFT ON THE MEXICO SIDE OF THE
U.S. SOUTHERN BORDER?
I UNDERSTAND THE POSITION, TO
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION POLICIES
BUT MY QUESTION FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE SORT OF
CRITIQUING THE SITUATION RIGHT
NOW IS, WE ALWAYS HAVE TO ACCEPT
THE REALITY FOR WHAT IT IS, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
REVERSED THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY SO WHAT HAPPENS NOW IF
YOU REFUSE TO ADMIT THOUSANDS OF
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS INTO THE
UNITED STATES?
DO THEY LIVE HAPPILY EVER AFTER
OR ARE THEY NOW STRANDED ON THE
MEXICO SIDE OF THE U.S. SOUTHERN
BORDER AND BECOME MORE
VULNERABLE TO SEX TRAFFICKERS
AND COYOTES AND THE CARTELS?
OBVIOUSLY, SHANNON, I THINK THIS
IS WHAT YOU ARE GETTING AT WHEN
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT, WE NEED
SOLUTIONS, WE NEED LESS CRITIQUE
AND MORE ACCEPTING OF THE
REALITY AND PEOPLE GETTING ON
BOARD TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
SOLUTIONS.
MORE PEOPLE PUTTING THEIR HEADS
TOGETHER TO THE PROBLEM INSTEAD
OF JUST COMPLAINING ABOUT IT ALL
THE TIME.
>> Emily: HOPEFULLY THE BRIDGE
BETWEEN CANDIDATE KAMALA HARRIS
AND VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
BECOMES POSSIBLE AND SHE SHOULD
FIND SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS NOW
THAT SHE’S IN CHARGE OF THE